[Musique]
Laurent Garin donc on est au au pavier
du canal 35 ans qui a 35 ans oui tout à
fait 35 ans qu'elle est là qu'elle est
présente dans le dans le cœur de
montinier et de 50 ans en Eveline et on
reste tout à fait épendant dans nos
choix dans notre assortiment et dans nos
sélections oui c'est vrai que c'est une
vraie librairie avec en effet vous
conseillez des conseils a des petits
papiers sur les livres alors tout à fait
il y a l'accueil mais aussi d'abord il y
a la sélection donc il y a à peu près
80000 ouvrages là actuellement et chaque
ouvrage qui vient ici a été sélectionné
par une libraire c'est ça c'est c'est
des choix que vous faites vous êtes
combien de libraires alors on est une
vingtaine de personnes et il y a 13
libraires ici sur la surface de vente
ouis ça c'estd que c'est un peu une je
dire une grande surface de livra si si
on pourrait dire ça non mais c'est une
vraie librairie une vraie librairie et
en même temps on trouve absolument tout
c'est ça c'est une grosse entreprise où
chaque libraire pour le coup là et c'est
à sa sélection dans son propre rayon
donc on a une libraire qui va gérer que
la littérature française un autre qui va
gérer que la littérature traduite encore
le manga enfin voilà chaque rayon a son
propre libraire est-ce que parce qu'on
vous dit parfois le livre est en crise
et cetera j'ai l'impression moi qu'il y
a toujours autant de monde à la livr du
canal oui ben non non non nous ça reste
encore un très très beau cadeau avec une
forte plusvue en fait dans le cadeau
donc non non les gens apprécient encore
l'objet et ont besoin de cet objet de
tenir un livre de discuter autour du
livre de faire passer le livre alors on
va on va faire un petit peu le tour de
de cette librairie des des différents
rayons qui existent alors on va parler
de manga on va parler de beauart on va
parler de livre de cuisine on va parler
de de jeunesse on va parler de
littérature et de band dessiné également
et de band dessiné on aurait le tour et
on aura fait le tour et c'est bien et
alors dans chaque rayon ben il y a un
libraire spécialiste qui va qui va nous
nous guider c'est ça qui va nous
accueillir et qui va donc vous présenter
le bouquin le livre de la fin d'année
alors on va commencer par le mangas
[Musique]
d'accord alors Laurent là on va
retrouver la la responsable des mangas
tout à fait donc magalite ancré qui est
donc à la base de la création de cet
espace en fait c'est elle qui a beaucoup
travaillé à à ce que cet endroit puisse
exister et puisse continuer de vivre
donc voilà Magal ancrée bonjour Magalie
alors vous êtes une passionnée des
mangas depuis toujours euh oui depuis
toujours ça va faire 20 ans maintenant
j'ai commencé à 11 ans et avec un
premier manga qui s'appelle fruit de
basket et aujourd'hui ben j'en fais j'en
fais mon métier c'est je suis très
contente de vivre de ma passion Laurent
c'est c'est bien justement que dans une
librairie généraliste on trouve des
mangas bah oui tout à fait puis nous
c'est vraiment un espace qui est
proprement dédié au mangas donc voilà
c'est une librairie dans la librairie
voilà et sinon pour moi c'est plutôt le
club doroté qui m'a emmené au manga donc
moi je suis de la génération donc on
parle beaucoup de jeune génération c'est
vrai que c'est vrai qu'il y avait les
premiers dessins animés japonais et donc
les vieux comme moi on vient en manga
grâce au club de roté voilà alors là on
est dans dans dans votre royaume donc
magaliie donc c'est vous qui choisissez
les livres qui qui arrive enfin voilà ce
que vous conseillez évidemment
exactement j'ai la main mise sur
vraiment chaque ouvrage qu'il y a ici si
je le veux c'est vraiment du parti prix
c'est que j'ai envie qu'il soit là pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les lecteurs
puissent le trouver et quisit vraiment
de tout ici alors bah on va on va parler
de votre sélection voilà si si on devait
acheter des livres pour les fêtes
qu'est-ce que vous conseilleriez-vous
alors je conseillerais la cantine de
minuit qui est un un ouvrage parue au
lésard noir qui parle d'un Nakaya qui
est une sorte de bistro japonais ouvert
de de 19h à 7h du matin et on suit un
gérant à
l'intérieur qui fait qui fait des plats
qui prépare en fait selon tout
simplement les la nourriture qu'il a
avec lui qui prépare des petits plats
différents tous les jour un pan mais
vraiment global de la société japonaise
il est pas question de lycée pour faire
venir du tourisme ou quoi que ce soit
comme les guidees là il est question de
montrer toute la complexité de la
société japonaise que ce soit le mal des
gaijin donc ces étrangers les Japonais
qui ont mal avec les étrangers de les
accepter et aussi de montrer tout le
mal-être de la société japonaise à
vers les salaran qui doivent vraiment
travailler jour et nuit pour leur
entreprise et qui viennent dans ces dans
ces petits bistr pour boire et manger
loin de chez eux et puis reprendre le
lendemain le travail ça donne pas très
envie d'aller au Japon ou d'aller vivre
au Japon aussi alors d'aller vivre
effectivement non ça non par contre pour
y avoir été c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit pas forcément parce que c'est que
la nuit mais sinon de jours on voit on
va vraiment autre chose et c'est ça que
aussi très intéressant ce qui est très
intéressant moi je connais rien du tout
dans dans les mangas mais ça prouve que
voilà c'est pas seulement un
divertissement ça peut aborder aussi des
problèmes de fond quoi oui aujourd'hui
le manga se complexifie se diversifie il
est pas non plus question de
donner des des récits pour les jeunes
d'action d'aventure on fait aujourd'hui
beaucoup de mangas pour les plus de 25
ans pour les adultes sur le mala de la
société japonaise ù même
des des des histoires beaucoup plus
complexes plus matures je dirais oui
c'est c'est quel âge ça la cantine de
minuit ou je dirais vraiment à partir de
16 ans à partir du moment où on
s'intéresse en fait à la société
japonaise où on veut savoir ce qu'il en
est réellement et ne pas avoir un aspect
vraiment censuré au lycée donc la qutine
de minuit premier choix il y a il y a
d'autres conseil que vous voulez nous
donner euh je pourrais oui il y en a un
qui me tient particulièrement à cœur ça
s'appelle il s'appelle Césare il est aux
édition
kiun et lui par contre il met en avant
l'une les icônes de la Renaissance
italienne cheésar Borgia ouais qui qui
est vraiment donc on le connaît pour
avoir donné le prince de machavel ouais
et on a donc fouyumi mangaka qui a passé
des heures et des heures avec des
spécialistes de la Renaissance italienne
qui a une bibliographie énorme à chaque
fin d'ouvrage et qui veut vraiment de
don donner au lecteurs toute la vision
c'est vraiment la vision de Cesare c'est
pas l'histoire du personnage et sa
vision à travers une histoire romancée
avec des personnages un personnage aussi
qui n'a jamais existé Angelo mais qui
assiste Césaré et qui est là pour le
faire parler donc pour nous faire
comprendre et partager sa vision pour
les béien comme moi quelle est la
différence entre le manga et la BD le
manga est ce qui est pour nous
occidentaux la la la BD pour eux c'était
c'est ça depuis okusil après il y a eu
toute une évolution vous avez eu
osamutezuka qui est vraiment qui est le
maître et qui a fait en sorte que le
manga soit ce qu'il est aujourd'hui et
vous avez d'autres grands noms Naoki
ourzawa qui est passé aussi par derrière
et qui a donné une autre complexité
scénaristique avec un mélange de
policiers de de fantastique à
l'intérieur qui ont permis de faire
évoluer le Manga pour faire en sorte
qu'il soit ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
voilà alors la qutine nu nuuit c'esttait
sociologique si je peux dire ces arrês
plutôt historique est-ce qu'il y a des
des des choses de pur divertissement
pour des plus jeunes ou ah oui eu et
bien pour les plus jeunes vous avez euh
vous avez de très bons mangas qui
abordent aussi des Ben des sujets comme
la fantaisie le le fantastique ben vous
avez les légendaires saga donc qui ont
été adaptés en mangas les légendaires
donc on connaît la BD la BD française et
donc les les auteurs ont décidé aussi de
se jouer au jeu du manga pour
pouvoir faire un dynamisme différent
dans dans l'histoire et parfois aussi
rattraper les petites erreurs qui ont
été commises par-ci par là voilà et et
puis toucher aussi le jeune public du
manga qui est très très très très bien
je trouve pour les enfants donc voilà
bah si si on a envie de manga il suffit
de venir ici de demander conseils hein
tout à fait on vous accueillera avec
plaisir Laurent on va continuer avec la
jeunesse hein
alors il faut descendre là maintenant il
faut descendre donc là on va traverser
le tourisme avec ses beau livres ses
guides de tourisme et juste à côté le
parascolaire voilà ah c'est génial oui
là aussi il y a il y a toute une
librairie de tourisme oui ça peut ça
peut faire aussi des beau Cau ça tout à
fait et les récits de voyage également
voilà important le ré de voyage TR
absolument Laurent Garin donc jeunesse
donc tout à fait dans le royaume de
Valérie botané où elle a uvré aussi
énormément ici pour que ça explose de
partout au niveau de l'offre au niveau
des livres au niveau de la sélection
bonjour Valérie bonjour la littérature
jeunesse c'est une passion pour vous oui
bah ça fait 21 ans que j'exerce ce
métier et oui je je trouve que c'est
très riche il y a vraiment de tout on
peut aller du tout petit nouveau-né à
l'adulte aussi parce que on a un grand
public en fait qui lit de la littérature
adolescente donc c'est un un rayon très
varié je dis toujours que c'est une mini
librairie en fait en un seul rayon voilà
je me souens que un des gros écrivain
qui s'appelle Michel Tournier qui
écrivait aussi pour la la jeunesse il
disait que bah le le meilleur de ce
qu'il faisait c'était c'était les livres
pour la jeunesse même dans son style bah
il a raison puisque en fait c'est
l'endroit où on peut être le plus
créatif le plus
original imaginatif en effet parce que
un enfant il est très ouvert surtout en
fait il se met pas de barrières c'est
souvent l'adulte qui met des barrières
sur ça donc c'est un rayon on s'éclate
enfin disons les choses voilà alors pour
les fêtes vous allez nous proposer trois
types hein de livres on va essayer de
varier un petit peu sous les tranches
d'âge on va commencer par les entre deux
plus petits et puis après je vais monter
cresendo sur les tranches d'â je vais
vous montrer on commence avec ce livre
alors c'est pour les petits alors pas si
petit que ça et je trouve que c'est même
quelque chose qui pourrait s'ouvrir
aussi au public adulte c'est Baptiste
baaulieu au
texte on a deux yeux pour voir
exactement en fait il nous présente
l'histoire d'un enfant qui a une sorte
d'anomalie pas une difficulté mais une
anomalie un petit peu étrange un œil
étoile et un œil lune selon le regard
qu'il a enfin selon qui ferme l'œil
l'œil lune va être plutôt dans les
choses positives l'œil étoile va être
plutôt dans les choses négatives donc
c'est vraiment comme une parabole pour
dire que les enfants ont cette capacité
en fait de regarder des choses toujours
positivement ou plutôt négativement et
en fait tout l'album va nous proposer en
fait les deux visions que l'enfant
pourrait avoir dans la toute première
situation par exemple il va avoir un SDF
dans la rue donc dans son œil négatif il
voit le froid il voit le l'isolation la
solitude et quand il ferme l'autre œil
là petit miracle il voit les petits
détails et dans les dans le vêtement de
ce SDF il y a un petit chat tout
grelotant un petit chaton et qui est
très heureux et qui se réjouit
finalement d'avoir trouvé cet adulte qui
va le réchauffer et qui va permettre
finalement d'aller mieux et en fait tout
l'album va être comme ça où on voit cet
enfant qui va grandir et qui espère que
même quand il va devenir adulte il
pourra garder en fait fait cet œil cette
cette posibilité et cette un peu
négativité mais que voir le monde en
fait avec ses deux yeux c'est un c'est
beau d'ailleurs parce que c'est ce qu'on
a tous hein on voit toujours le monde
avec deux yeux et je trouve que l'album
les illustrations sont très belles voilà
le fameux que je vous montrait tout à
l'heure donc le petit chat qu'on voyait
pas dans le détail et
finalement il va grandir et on espère on
laisse une porte ouverte finalement
est-ce que quand il sera plus grand il
gardera encore cette âme d'enfant
finalement voilà euh c'est très bien ur
et qui fonctionne aussi bien pour les
adultes que pour les jeunes enfants
voilà donc on a deux yeux pour voir de
Baptiste bulieu et c'est les éditions
Les Arènes les ares alors c'est cet
album que je voudrais vous présenter qui
s'appelle mon encyclopédie animée c'est
éditions galimar qui font ça galimar
jeunesse donc c'est pour la tranche
d'âge 5 8 ans donc on est finalement pas
si loin que ça de l'album oui l'autre
c'était quel âge moi je mettais 5 ans
aussi l'âge minimal mais après comme je
vous disais j'ai beaucoup de public
adulte en fait parce que comme Baptiste
bol est très les réseaux sociaux aussi
qui l'ont acheté pour eux-mêmes parce
que c'est vraiment un très joli message
là on est en effet dans quelque chose
pour les enfants en fait vous avez des
petits volets des fenêtres à ouvrir il y
en a 180 à l'intérieur euh qui vont
avoir pour inform formatif découvertes
plein de détail plein de choses sur les
animaux sur la nature sur le quotidien
voilà exactement et donc ce jeu de petit
volet petite fenêtre fait qu'un enfant
qui même n'est pas encore lecteur peut
s'amuser à regarder à ouvrir et après
par contre s'il est déjà dans la lecture
il va apprendre il va pouvoir découvrir
tout cela et c'est vraiment une
collectionction bien sûr au contraire
d'accord et on apprend beaucoup de
choses et c'est une vraie forme
originale je trouve que voilà mag c'est
un titre qui qui est assez ouvert et qui
voilà parle je pense à plein de public
et après vous avez je vois il y en a par
exemple sur le corps plus spécialisé sur
le corps humain exactement c'est
l'avantage en fait c'est ce que je
disais c'est une mini librairie à
l'intérieur il y a des choses qui sont
plus généralistes donc comme une
encyclopédie mais on peut parler
d'électricité avec réaliser un circuit
électrique on peut faire aussi
l'histoire on peut avoir aussi le côté
féministe avec les femmes qui ont fait
l'histoire de la BD qui qui en évoque
euh c'est ça aussi
la la générosité du rayon jeunesse
absolument et le allez trè choix le
troème choix là on va partir chez les
grands ados parce que je voulais
absolument mettre le le point d'or sur
la pépite de monreil qui est décerné à
an lbondou que nous avons mis la chance
oui exactement qui vient tout just
d'être remis qui se destine à un public
plus de 14 ans voir adulte et qui voilà
est une grande œuvre pour moi on va la
vous nous le montrez alors ce trème
choix alors c'est la pépite d'or de
monreuil c'est nous traverserons les
orages de Anel Bondou pépite d'or c'est
quoi c'est le c'est la plus grande
récompense du Salon de Montreuil oui qui
est le
salon exactement qui vient de se
terminer qui vient cltur euh normalement
chaque année c'est plutôt un album qui
est mis en avant ça fait très longtemps
qu'il y a pas eu de romans de romans en
plus ado donc qui se destine un public
un peu plus grand euh on va suivre en
fait l'histoire d'une famille euh la
famille baguerre qui euh va on va la
suivre sur un siècle complet c'est une
histoire masculine ça change un petit
peu anler Bondou a mis beaucoup de
choses de sa vie personnel euh on va
suivre une famille qui est assez dans le
Morvent euh le Morvent est connu quand
même pour être être âpre un peu très
venteux c'est un peu difficile de vivre
et là on va suivre donc une famille
d'agriculteurs euh donc cette famille a
une particularité tous les hommes
portent un nom d'arbre voilà on va voir
sol Olivier euh j'ai plus tous les noms
en tête mais en tout cas et on va les
suivre à travers les différents
événements de l'histoire de la petite
guerre enfin de la Grande Guerre 1418
guerre d'Algérie les évolutions du temps
les chocs pétroliers on va vraiment
suivre tout ce qui va chambouler cette
famille les secrets de famille euh les
mariages l'évolution du temps aussi euh
c'est un roman
apre généreux euh qui nous donne
vraiment envie de suivre et de découvrir
qu'est-ce qu'il est parce que tous ces
petits secrets de famille on a envie de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'il en est on a un
narrateur qui connaît tout mais qui va
apparaître que à la fin et c'est ça
aussi l'originalité c'est qu'on ne sait
pas qui nous raconte l'histoire parce
que c'est un narrateur externe ou
finalement euh c'estou quelqu'un de la
famille ou la famille ou autour de la
famille mais pardon parce que euh voilà
c'est un gros livre d'abord hein euh euh
vous nous racontez une histoire en en
quoi c'est un livre pour la jeunesse
parce que on va suivre en fait pas des
adultes au départ ce sont des
adolescents euh qui vont grandir qui
vont chacun va donner une lignée euh qui
reste encore un côté enfantin pour leur
toute leur jeunesse en fait c'est ça qui
est vraiment le point d'orgue de
l'histoire c'est qu'on voit les
jeunesses de ces jeunes qui vont les qui
vont constituer leur vie qui vont
les armées finalement sur le long terme
et on va les voir grandir et Anne
lbondou réussi en fait le tour de force
de de nous embarquer en fait à chaque
fois sur un nouvel un nouvel enfant et
de le voir grandir et de le voir évoluer
tout en gardant quand même toujours la
trace de de cet enfant Grandu qui a
grandi pardon qui est devenu un adulte
voilà nous traverserons des orages ce
qui est un magnifique titre aussi ça
c'est quel âge parce que c'est là vous
dis des adultes qui disent la
littérature pour enfants celui-là les
adultes peuvent le lire aussi non
totalement complètement puisqueen plus
on suiv vraiment le côté historique de
l'histoire donc on a on apprend beaucoup
de choses il est sorti en septembre et
moi c'est un grand une grande part de
public adulte qui l' acheté aussi pour
eux voilà et c'est un grand coup de cœur
pour vous énorme coup de cœur
complètement merci beaucoup donc bah il
y a des des centaines évidemment
d'autres d'autres livres pour la
jeunesse le tout c'est de venir à la
librairie du canal faire ses choix et
avec vous qui allez les conseiller
merveilleusement merci beaucoup on
essaiera en tout cas voilà Laurent euh
c'est c'est moi je suis fasciné parce
que vous avez vous avez une équipe
formidable oui bah oui ils sont plein
mais c'est ça en fait qui fait la trait
aussi des libraires indépendant c'est
qu'il y a plein de libraires qui
accueillent le public et qui sont formés
et qui ont lu des livres et qui savent
aussi proposer faire des pas de côté aux
gens en fait les gens souvent viennent
avec des idées un peu préconçues sur
voilà je voudrais ceci ou cela et
finalement ils ressortent avec un livre
qui est tout à fait à l'opposé de ce
qu'ils étaient venus chercher et voilà
et c'est ça aussi le bonheur des
librairies indépendantes alors on
continue on continue avec quoi on va
continuer avec la bande desessiné les
comics et les
romangraphiques
alors lur maintenant on va parler de de
BD de romraphique de comics tout à fait
donc le le domaine de la bande dessinée
francobge donc les romans graphiques les
romans graphiques avec des sciences
humaines également sur lesquel on a fait
un rayon qui lui est propre et le comic
qui est le format américain des bandes
dessinées et avec une spécialiste comme
toujours donc Elodie Persico qui est la
responsable de tout ce domaine là
bonjourodie bonjour enchanté alors
questions que je pose à chacun des des
libraire qui qui nous parle de de son
rayon vous êtes vous aussi une
passionnée de quoi de bande dessinée de
comics une bande dessinée de une une
passionnée de livres déjà en en tout he
que ce soit la jeunesse la littérature
et cetera et bah là ça va faire
24 ans que je m'occupe de la bande
dessinée ah oui donc vous connaissez
tout euh peut-être pas tout non
heureusement pour moi il y en a encore à
découvrir et et justement il y a du
nouvellement il y a il y a des comme ça
des des des livres que vous recevez donc
vous dites ça c'est ça c'est formidable
je je connaissais pas ça oui
heureusement alors cette année il y a
quand même énormément de suites
d'énormes blockbusters donc je pense que
tout le monde a sorti sa suite de fin
d'année cette année le Astérix le black
et Mortimer le black sad LEF voilà on a
toutes les suites mais heureusement il y
a aussi des pépites il y a des très
beaux
collectors intégral enfin ils ont voilà
c'est une très très belle fin d'année BD
alors on va commencer par deux livres
qui sont ici oui tout à fait des beaux
livres de fin d'année que j'avais envie
de mettre en avant même si je pense que
ils ont déjà un public mais là cette
année particulièrement il y a vraiment
de très très belles choses qui ont été
faites alors on commence par quoi alors
on va commencer par le wi
Wika ah oui il est beau il est
magnifique
hein d'abord c'est un bel objet oui
exactement c'est un très bel objet voilà
ils ont fait un travail magnifique on
est sur l'intégral de la série donc
voilà on s'achète al un mot sur Wika
parce que par exemple moi je ne connais
pas alors Wika c'est une série de le
droit c'est pas forcément la plus connue
je dirais que la plus connue c'est quand
même les Chroniques de la Lune Noire qui
ont fait vraiment son apogé depuis il a
sorti quelques séries beaucoup plus
courtes avec une vraie fin ce qui est
assez formid et là Wika c'est l'histoire
donc on est dans le monde des faits donc
c'est vraiment du de la fantaisie
l'histoire d'une fée qui a été à qui on
a pris son enfance et sa jeunesse ses
parents ont été assassinés quand elle
était toute petite et elle va devoir
prendre sa place et découvrir qui elle
est et ce qu'elle peut apporter au monde
et et alors oui c'est vrai que c'est
édité alors c'est des dessins absolument
incroyables alors ça form000 de de de dé
détails
exactement on se fais du B on se faisait
la réflexion l'autre fois avec les
collègues tout a été travaillé que ce
soit même les les filactèes tout est
inclus dans le dessin il y a rien qui
choque c'est c'est magnifique ouis c'est
des vraies œuvres d'art donc voilà donc
Glen travail d'éditeur plus exactement
ou ou ouit chez qui glena glena a fait
un magnifique travail et a vraiment
remis à l'honneur cette série qui pour
moi a était un coup de cœur depuis de
nombreuses années mais là je le
redécouvre là voilà alors deuxième choix
enfin deuxième choix pas deuxième choix
c'est autre choix possible en tout cas
bah c'est celui-là bah bien sûr ah mais
c'est l'intégral ou quoi l'intégral ah
la vache génial l'intégral de l'Arab rou
de rat saouf oui voilà donc ils ont
gardé le format original donc ça se lit
aussi bien c'est un très beau
papier c'est pas si lourd moi je trouve
ça plutôt agréable à lire je les ai lu
pour les relis ah benah alors voilà moi
je les ai lu en tô séparé au fur et à
mesure où ils sont sortis et jusqu'à
maintenant j'avais pas passé le pas je
me suis dit bon je les ai lu et mais non
là j'ai craqué en fait ou ouais oui là
je me le suis offert quand on a alors
ceux qui n'ont pas lu évidemment c'est
une découverte et ceux qui ont lu on
retrouve les premiers exactement donc on
a l'histoire complète il est vendu avec
un exlibris donc qui a été retiré pour
l'instant pour que les gens puissent
feuilleter le l'ouvrage et voilà on donc
on a l'histoire de Riad satouf de son
enfance jusqu'à ses premiers succès
jusqu'à son voilà son vrai
succès ça c'est c'est évidemment un
bestseller un bestseller tout à fait et
là pareil je trouve que l'éditeur a fait
un très joli travail on a vraiment il
est il est sublimé le dos toilé le voilà
c'est c'est un magnifique magnifique ou
objet collectur et il y a qu'un seul
tirage ah oui ah oui il ne sera pas
refait donc il sera pas il sera pas
retiré exement donc dépêchez-vous
dépêchez-vous on en a en a pour
l'instant cette odeur du papier qui est
bien significative de ouais de l'œuvre
ouis non on re ouais on y retourne on y
retourne ouais c'est un plaisir euh
voilà alors peut-être un coup de cœur
allez alors au cœur des solitudes
donc au cœur des solitudes c'est un
magnifique objet
pareil hein ils ont fait une une
couverture même qui n'est pas pelliculée
donc on est vraiment sur du
papier voilà et et avec un intérieur
absolument sublime noir et blanc noir et
blanc on est sur du noir et blanc on est
pareil sur un très joli papier et un
récit que j'ai trouvé très joli et en
plus très intéressant puisqu'on nous
raconte l'histoire de John Muir qui est
le premier écologiste au monde voilà
John Muir travaillait dans dans
une dans une entreprise il était très
ferru de
mécanique jusqu'au jour où il a été
blessé aux yeux donc il perd la vue
pendant plusieurs mois il sait même pas
si un jour il pourra revoir et il se met
à rêver de ce qu'il aurait aimé faire de
sa vie et il va se rendre compte qu'en
fait ce qu'il aimait qui revient de son
enfance en fait c'était vraiment la
découverte de la flore donc il décide de
partir à travers les États-Unis de
traverser les États-Unis à pied et de
découvrir la flore sur place voilà alors
on a son histoire on a ses rencontres
donc on est quand même dans un pays qui
où les Indiens commencent à être parqués
où il va il y a le racisme et cetera
donc il il y a pas que la flore il y a
toutes ces rencontres ces rencontres
avec les propriétaires terriens et
cetera et puis ce que j'ai trouvé
vraiment très très intéressant c'est que
sur la fin on a l'histoire de John Muir
donc elle est vrai voilà donc là c'est
la vraie histoire aussi mais une partie
de son histoire et là on a vraiment
exactement sabio qu'est-ce qu'il est
devenu à la suite de de ce fabuleux
voyage voilà c'est un auteur français
américain l'omig français français qui
était venu en dédicace pour son album
précédent à la librerie de Bretagne de
BR un français de Bretagne voilà un
Breton donc au cœur des solitudes au
cœur des solitudes tout ben merci merci
beaucoup donc évidemment il y a il y a
des centaines d'autres ouvrages
possibles il suffit de venir encore une
fois vous voir à les livreries du canal
merci beaucoup avec plaisir
[Musique]
merci depuis depuis le début je parle de
de la librie du canal le vrai nom c'est
le pavé du canal c'est ça tout à fait le
pavé du canal al libr du canal on les
aime beaucoup mais ils sont à Basti
c'est le pavé du canal c'est ça parce
que le le fondateur était 68ard et les
pavés forcément pour lui ça c'est une
vraie résonance mais je me suis je l'ai
reçu j'ai j'ai connu tout à fait alors
on est dans le rayon beau livre livre
d'art beau livre vie pratique vie
pratique et on va commencer par la
cuisine avec Sylvain gedrosac qui est
donc un tout nouveau libraire qu'on a
été tout heureux d'accueillir en milieu
d'année et qui donc qui gère la vie
pratique et également un bout des
sciences humaines alors silv bonjour
bonjour Patrice comment ça va ça va très
bien bah je suis heureux parce que là on
va parler parler un peu bouff quoi
bienvenue en cuisine alors j'ai un coup
de cœur je veux absolument vous le
montrer c'est mon coup de cœur de
l'année donc je commence par celui-là
est-ce que vous connaissez Marseille
Patrice je connais un peu Marseille oui
alors vous vous est-ce que vous aimez
Marseille j'aime asse bien je vais
souvent au PSG donc faut pas que je dise
trop fort mais non alors vous vous avez
j'aime bien Marseille vous avez un avis
en tout cas vous n'êtes pas dans le je
ne sais pas non non c'est non c'est
magnifique Marseille et en fait c'est
c'est c'est assez rare pour une ville
française tout le monde a un avis sur
Marseille qu'on habite Marseille ou pas
on a tous un avis sur Marseille beaucoup
de copains Marseillais en plus voilà
parce que c'est une ville je pense qui
cristallise beaucoup de choses qui
cristallise la passion les engouements
aussi les clichés parfois qui sont
toujours un petit peu réducteur
malheureusement et qui qui cristallise
aussi parfois peut-être les regrets on
aimerait que Marseille soit un petit peu
différente donc on a tous un avis
là-dessus et en fait la vérité c'est que
je pense que s'il y a une alchimie qui
se fait dans le cerveau des Français dès
qu'on prononce le mot Marseille c'est
parce que marseille est une ville assise
sur un patrimoine culturel absolument
génial on connaît tous on connaît tous
alors quand je parle de culture je parle
de culture de tous les jours le
patrimoine le patrimoine immatériel sur
je parle aussi des personnalités on
connaît tous tapis g de ah bah voilà en
même temps Zida et sa femme
voilà
Edmond charlerou voilà vous avez failli
me me me me planter là donc il y a
Zidane et cetera il y AAM il y a jou
dans il y a tous les rappeurs c'est la
ville du rap maintenant et puis on
connait tous la Cannebière on connait
tous le le le théâtre de la criere on
connait le le Musem le Musem magnifique
voilà donc je pense que le la bouille à
baisse alors ouais mais au-delà de ça il
y a pas que la bouille à baisse alors
moi je suis dans le cliché voilà le la
bouill à baisse le pastiss les navettes
et cetera justement ce livre là V
travailler à l'office du tourisme de
Marseille ouais non mais je veux
vraiment marseillais non pas du pas du
tout et justement il y a plein de
Parisiens qui aiment Marseille il faut
pas voilà donc au-delà des clichés le
l'auteur qui s'appelle Ezéquiel zera
vous propose Marseille un jour sans fin
F voilà jeu de mot et c'est un c'est un
livre qui est sorti chez achè Cuisine et
c'est génial parce qu'en fait il nous
propose un voyage culinaire à Marseille
sur une journée type sur 25h alors 25
pas 24 parce qu'à Marseille on fait
toujours plus que plus que les autres et
en fait c'est 24 petits voyages dans la
la gastronomie je dirais même la bouffe
à Marseille dans le bon sens du terme
alors dit la gastronomie c'est les
recettes c'est c'est les établissements
alors justement c'est en fait c'est vu
sur un grand panorama le spectre est
très large vous allez avoir des recettes
évidemment de la soupe au pistou par
exemple vous allez avoir la la recette
de la Yoli mais au-delà de ça vous allez
avoir aussi des témoignages des
témoignages de cuisinière de cuisiniers
vous allez avoir des des des témoignages
de commerce ambulant qui font aussi
partie de la gastronomie marseillaise
vous allez avoir des des témoignages de
serveurs de sererveus et cetera et vous
allez avoir plein de petits reportages
sur des petits des petits aspects qu'on
connaît pas forcément par exemple j'ai
appris dans ce livre qu'à côté de la
prison des baaettes il y a un restaurant
qui s'appelle les beau mets donc c'est
c'est un jeu de mot et en fait c'est un
restaurant qui est tenu par des
prisonniers donc tout le monde peut y
aller enfin il faut être adulte il faut
faut avoir un quasi judiciaire vide et
on sert pas d'alcool enfin vierge et on
sert pas d'alcool on sert des mocktails
des cocktails sans alcool mais c'est
tenu par des prisonniers donc ça moi je
l'avais lu nulle part je le connaissais
pas alors que je connais un petit peu
Marseille on apprend aussi qu'à côté
d'auagne entre auagne et Marseille il y
a une société qui fait des marrons
glacés et en fait c'est l'un des leaders
mondiaux des marrons glacés tous les ans
il y a des millions de marrons glacés
qui viennent de Marseille qui vont dans
dans le monde entier donc on apprend
tout ça on apprend que laurangina par
exemple a été créé en Algérie mais ça a
été importé à Marseille au 19e siècle à
la fin du 19e et depuis voilà c'est une
c'est une boisson qui a
mé un petit peu partout dans dans le
monde entier donc vous allez voir en
plus la mise en jou des portraits de
chef aussi he ça ouais il y a des
portraits de chef réfugiés notamment des
portraits de chef qui sont très connus
qui travaillent aussi à Paris parfois
enfin voilà et moi ce que j'aime surtout
çati qui est l'architecte du Musem voilà
donc vous voyez il y a des dessin il y a
des photos il y a des vieilles pubs la
mise en page est vraiment très belle
c'est une espèce de collage de collage
qu'aurait pas renié cocto ou ou Boris VI
évidemment la cité du du fata et cetera
voilà donc ça c'était mon premier coup
de cœur Patrice très
bien du canal c'est l'un des des clous
de de cette saison j'ai un autre petit
livre alors là qui est qui est complèt
ouais complètement à contrecourant c'est
un livre de cuisine qui n'a pas de
photos donc c'est assez assez original
parce que généralement justement on a
des beaux livres avec des belles photos
là il y en a pas parce que je crois que
le livre le plus fondu c'est c'est
simplissime ENF justement oui oui disait
il faut une photo qui la photo est plus
grande que le texte voilà c'est ça c'est
la photo qui donne envie de réaliser qui
donne qui qui nous met en appéti ou bien
et là en fait c'est Jean-François pièche
qui est un très grand chef connu surtout
à Paris mais qui commence à mer un petit
peu puis on le voit souvent à la télé
qui propose un répertoire pour tous les
jours c'est un vrai répertoire comme
quand on était petit vous savez qu'on
essayait d'apprendre des des mots de
vocabulaire en anglais ou en espagnol là
en fait il propose c'est alphabétique ça
il propose 34 rubriques il suffit
d'aller sur la page de garde on sait ce
qu'on veut par exemple c'est c'est tard
enfin il est déjà midi on est samedi on
veut faire une meringue voilà on voit
que la meringue est en 24 on va sur le
le petit onglet numéro 24 tout
simplement et là on a la recette de la
meringue la plus simple possible mais il
y a aussi des meringues plus compliqué
VO ah oui ça va êre du plus simple plus
compé voilà donc on peut l'avoir dans la
poche sur le comptoir enfin sur le plan
de travail et bon il sera un petit peu
abîmé un petit peu sale mais voilà c'est
un c'est un L de T pas trop donc il y a
des choses faciles c'est c'est facile
les grands chefs souvent c'est un peu
compliqué mais il y a deux versions
justement la première version c'est la
plus simple la tarte et cetera et après
on peut rentrer dans de la gastronomie
et en plus ch du tout c'est 25 € voilà
une idé des cadeaux qui peuvent plaire
àidé à beaucoup voilà ben merci beaucoup
merci il y en a plein d'autres
évidemment il y en a plein d'autres
suffit de venir vous voir voilà on
explique on essaie de voir ce que les
gens apprécient quel type de cadeau ils
veulent faire et on est là pour eux
normalement après on goûte les recettes
qui ont été faites normalement oui vous
fait on vous devez installer un petit
non non c'est prévu oui c'est prévu on
en dit pas plus mais c'est prévu merci
beaucoup Laurent on continue avec les
beau livres tout à fait avec donc
Stéphanie Ferial qui est la libraire
littérature normalement mais qui fait
pas que de la littérature dans la vie
qui regarde aussi beaucoup les bzards
qui aime beaucoup la photo donc là elle
va nous présenter un livre autour de la
photographie oui Stéphanie on se
connaitt hein bonjour tout à fait oui
vous était venu parler de justement de
littérature oui et là vous allez nous
parler d'un beau livre qui un beau
cadeau quoi tout à fait un beau cadeau
un beau livre de photos qui est assez
exceptionnel enfin moi que j'ai trouvé
absolument sublime qui est une
monographie de toutes les photos de
Vincent Munier euh qui est Vincent
Munier Vincent Munier est un photographe
animalier paysagiste aussi euh qui
s'inspire beaucoup de sa région il est
originaire desvuges et puis aussi du
peintre le Laurin et il s'inspire
justement d'une phrase qu'a dit le
Laurin qui est de capter un peu
l'invisible capter du coup d'essayer de
capter ce qui ne se voit pas ou du moin
pas beaucoup qui sont comme la lumière
la brume l'air
euh voilà donc du coup on a un recueil
il a ici alors peut-être des photos
qu'on a vu par ailleurs dans d'autres
recueils mais on les a c'est un intégral
là c'est un intégral si je pu dire en
tout cas c'est une monographie complète
euh on va on va surtout l'ouvrir oui oui
c'est c'est lui qui en parle le
mieux
eu voilà alors il a il a beaucoup œuvré
en Arctique en Antarctique beaucoup donc
dans les vuges aussi bien sûr beaucoup
en Afrique il a fait un petit peu un
petit peu le tour du monde si je puis
dire le résultat ce sont un peu comme
des tableaux de maître alors que ce sont
des oui c'est magnifique on voit tout
d'un coup on se retrouve face à un ours
on a on croise le regard d'un d'un yak
par exemple bah ne serait-ce que la
couverture bah c'est un albatros tout
simplement qu'on voit au milieu dans
dans le dans le livre alors il a une
capacité par exemple à montrer la neige
le blanc c'est ce qui a je trou depuis à
faire en art les Japonais le savaient
très très bien le faire le savent encore
et en photo c'est pas toujours évident
par exemple ce renard ou du moins c'est
un oui c'est un renard rou je sais pas
moi je trouve que finalement il y a
beaucoup de ça ressemble à la petite
sirène j'ai un peu de couleur dans la
photo et puis moi quand je l'ai vu j'ai
vu j'ai vu la petite sirène ce renard
qui voilà il arrive à capter quelque
chose qui est comme
d'éphémère et comme un temps suspendu
moi j'aime bien son travail pour ça ça
démarche c'est non seulement d'aimer
énormément effectivement la nature de
faire passer cette cet amour cette
passion parce que il il il il l'aime
énormément il en a il la respecte
énormément et ce qu'il y a surtout c'est
qu'il prend le temps de et aujourd'hui
on prend plus le temps de quel que soit
ce que l'on fait il faut toujours courir
lui il va prendre le temps c'est un peu
ce que disait syva Tesson dans le P des
c'est ça oui oui bah tout à fait voilà
c'est ça tout à fait mais d'ailleurs
Tesson est parti avec lui oui absolument
c'est pour ça que je dis ça
par et et justement il y avait tout ce
tout ce texte sur bah prenons le temps
quoi il faut prendre le temps et c'est
le contraire de notre civilisation
d'aujourd'hui tout à fait et d'ailleurs
il y a un texte al l'introduction est
faite donc par Munier où il raconte
comment est-ce qu'effectivement il en
est venu à la à la photographie et il y
a une une petite conclusion enfin un
texte de Tesson lui-même admiratif
effectivement de son travail voilà
magnifique c'est effectivement sublime
c'est un très très beau cadeau même si
enfin on aime à la fois la photo les
grand grands espaces les animaux c'est
très
épuré moi ce sont des photos c'est des
œuvres d'art quoi ce sont des œuvres
d'art tout à fait ben merci beaucoup
c'est alors il y a plein de plein
d'autres évidemment livres d'art qu'on
peut venir consulter vous vous les
consillerz mais ça c'est votre coup de
cœur he cel oui tout à fait c'est s'il y
en a un à offrir c'est celui-là voilà
vous êtes d'accord oui complètement moi
si je peux me permettre il y a qui
j'arrête on il y a un super beau ouvrage
sur qui j' donc c'est le seul rayon où
je vais me permettre une petite touche
personnelle donc pour les amoureux de il
est juste là voilà ça c'est votre oui
alors on avait reçu Rachid benzine qui
avait ouvert son livre autour de ce
concert de Cologne là c'est la
couverture c'est la pochette c'est ça
donc voilà un très très bel ouvrage pour
les amoureux de jazz et de Kar oui tous
les tous les HE tous les jours de votre
génération oui c'est ça ouais ouais de
ce disque hypnotique qu'on a pu écouter
et réécouter voilà ah merci beaucoup ben
c'est c'est bien comme ça on alors on va
finir avec peut-être un peu de
littérature et Stéphanie avec plaisir
avec plaisir je vous on va
[Musique]
rayon Laurent on est au rayon littéraire
alors il y a tous les romans évidemment
il y a évidemment tous les romans qui se
trouvent ici alors je pense que
l'intérêt du travail du libraire
indépendant il se trouve aussi dans la
littérature parce que ici on défend
toutes les petites maisons d'édition
indépendantes donc vraiment le travail
de libraire indépendant il trouve toute
sa couleur toute son ampleur en fait
dans cette défense ici de la littérature
que soit française comme traduite mais
en fait le fait est que des petites
maisons d'édition ont toute la place
dans nos rayons et et d'ailleurs il y a
les conseils il y a des petits mots qui
conseillent qui expliquent c'est ça de
gens qui ont lu le livre et qui savent
en parler donc oui il y a plein de
petites notules plein de petites mise en
avant de petits bouquins qu'on entend
dont on entend très très peu parler et
dans lesquels nous on peut pour le coup
discuter et mettre en avant stéphanieah
vous allez nous parler d'un d'un d'un
d'un beau livre mais avant puisque vous
lisez beaucoup de choses qui sortent
quel est votre coup de cœur dans l'année
dans les romans alors celui qui sera à
retenir ce serait l'amour de de Bodo oui
qui était vraiment voilà qui est
derrière
là très court et
justement 85 oui je sais plus exactement
80 pages et il arrive effectivement en
80 pages à raconter sur la vie d'un
couple ce qu'est l'amour comment il se
construit pas à pas comment la
complicité naî comment avec un petit
rien finalement on fait tout une vie
c'est absolument superbe et d'une
banalité d'un quotidien voilà il en fait
quelque chose d'exceptionnel faire de la
littérature avec le le le banal du
quotidien c'est vidable alors là on va
passer à un beau
livre d'une œuvre littéraire hyper connu
tout à fait voilà mais moi je m'en lasse
pas donc effectivement en littérature il
y a aussi quand même pas mal de beaux
livres et donc c'est l'île au trésor de
Stevenson que tout le monde connaît on a
peut-être pas forcément d'ailleurs lu
pas lu non mais on connaît on sait ce
que c'est voilà qui est superbement mis
en images et illustré aux éditions
saracan par donc je me souviens plus son
prénom excusez-moi Anton lomayef et donc
du coup ça donne par exemple alors l'île
au trésor effectivement pour moi c'est
le livre d'aventure par excellence on
s'en lasse pas on lit ça quand on a 10
12 ans ça traîne un peu dans les
bibliothèques des parents ou des
grands-parents et en fait en le relisant
on s'aperçoit que Ben tous les autres
livres voir même les grands films de
piraterie découlent de Stevenson c'est
absolument génial il y a de l'aventure
il y a des mutineries évidemment il y a
des tempêtes c'est une aventure sans fin
il y a des une chasse au trésor
absolument génial la carte au début donc
elle est là elle est toujours aussi
mystérieuse et on a envie de de H je
vais la retrouvé tout au début et puis
c'est un livre aussi d'initiation Jim
voilà Jim le héros il est tout jeune
voilà il vient de perdre son père il
essaie de faire en sorte que sa mère
puisse continuer à vivre voilà et et
puis l'autre personnage absolument
génial c'est effectivement Long John
Silver qui est mais indémodablef vir on
là dans la tête pour pendant longtemps
voilà donc lî au
trésor mais en fait c'est ça ça a
toujours le même effet mais je vois
alors il y a l'île au trésor mais je
vois que dans dans dans ce coin de la
librairie ben il y a il y a Rabo dans
une très belle édition c'est galimar je
pense il y a les les les fable de La
Fontaine illustrée par chagal tout c'est
vrai qu' il y a des des classiques qu'on
peut redécouvrir parce que ils sont ils
sont aussi des des beaux livres tout à
fait voilà c'est comment effectivement
redonner un petit peu de lumière à
certains textes qu'on a l'impression que
c'est un petit peu poussiéreux et en
fait voilà comme vous dites les fables
pour moi les fables voilà on on s'en
lasse pas non plus et voilà illustré par
chagal ou alors tout simplement illustré
par des par des des des grands maîtres
de l'estambe japonaise du du du début du
20e enfin fin 19e qui qui redonne en
fait un peu en lumière et qui redonne
goût aussi à ces textes que parfois on
lit à l'école sous la contrainte parfois
entre guillemets on est obligé alors que
là voilà on retombe dedans avec plaisir
tout simplement il le mag de stphan
Salambo en résonance un peu avec l'
trésor avec plein d'aventures partout en
très belle
édition voilà de Flobert
voilà c'est si vous voulez faire parfois
découvrir des des textes classiques
peut-être à des jeunes comme ça c'est
une bonne idée tout à fait c'est tout à
fait ça en fait c'est effectivement
offrir effectivement aussi des des des
livres dit classiques et sous une autre
forme moi quand j'étais gamine on m'a
offert Notre Dame de Paris illustré par
Gustave Doré je devis avoir 10 12 ans
ben je l'ai encore voilà et vous l'avez
lu vous l'avez lu je l'ai encore je l'ai
encore j'en suis j'en suis ça fait
partie de mon livre il me suit partout à
chaque déménagement oui ça a créé votre
vocation peut-être peut-être peut-être
effectivement c'est possible ça merci
beaucoup Stéphanie merci beaucoup
Laurent Laurent Garin alors pavé du
canal le pavé du canal non c'est un vrai
plaisir de montrer aussi tout notre
savoir-faire et tous ces libraires qui
savent accompagner les les les lecteur
et faire justement se promener un peu
dans tout ce monde éditorial qui est
vraiment hyper passionnant et hyper
diversifié dans tout diversifi et puis
c'est rare une librairie vous avez je
crois 12 libraires avec vous c'est ça
une douzaine de livraires avec nous et
une vingtaine de salariés ou c'est ça
salariés et ouais voilà c'est ce qui
fait la qualité de aussi d'un li parce
que ils sont tous passionnés ils sont
ils connaissent tout sur le rayon enfin
c'est formidable c'est des VO
spécialistes qui sont formés aussi une
vraie base de formation de librair et
donc qui peuvent accompagner les gens
effectivement en tout cas j'espère qu'on
vous a donné un peu envie voilà de
d'acheter quelques livres pour pour les
fêtes et puis de venir au pavé du canal
pour voilà c'est parce qu'il y a
d'autres parce que là c'est un tout
petit petit petit bout qu'on a montré
vir voir en vrai parce qu'on va vous
montrer tout ce qui reste derrière ou
qu'on a pas pu la montrer mais ce un
plaisir qu'on avec lequel on accueillera
les les gens merci beaucoup et puis à
très
[Musique]
bientôt